>> I'M PETE HEGSETH IN FOR LAURA
INGRAHAM.
WE START WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE LEARNED A DRONE STRIKE KILLED
AN ISIS-K PLANNER THAT WAS
BELIEVED TO BE CARRYING OUT
FUTURE ATTACKS ACCORDING TO THE
PENTAGON.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WARNING AMERICANS AT
THE KABUL AIRPORT TO LEAVE
IMMEDIATELY.
THE GATES ARE CLOSED.
TO THE LATEST AT THE PENTAGON,
LUCAS TOMLINSON IS STANDING BY.
>> LESS THAN 48 HOURS AFTER THE
DEADLY ATTACK THAT KILLED 13
SERVICE MEMBERS, THE U.S.
MILITARY HAS STRUCK BACK
LAUNCHING A DRONE STRIKE IN
EASTERN AFGHANISTAN.
THEY LEFT THE HEADQUARTERS OF
THE ISIS GROUP WHICH HAS CARRIED
OUT THE ATTACKS.
IN A STATEMENT FROM THE U.S.
CENTRAL COMMAND, CAPTAIN IRVIN
SAID "INITIAL INDICATIONS ARE
THAT WE KILLED THE TARGET.
WE KNOW OF NO CIVILIAN
CASUALTIES."
IF YOU REMEMBER PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID HE WOULD HUNT DOWN AND KILL
WHOEVER IS RESPONSIBLE.
IT WAS NOT CLEAR WHEN THEY WOULD
TAKE PLACE.
THE U.S. MILITARY IS PREPARING
TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
BREAKING NEWS AT THE PENTAGON,
THE U.S. MILITARY HAS STRUCK
BACK AND KILLED AN ISIS PLANNER.
I'M TOLD HE WAS KILLED IN A
VEHICLE AND KILLED WITH AN
ASSOCIATE WITH HIM.
AN AMERICAN DRONE STRIKE KILLED
AN ISIS PLANNER THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR CARRYING OUT
FUTURE ATTACKS.
NOT NECESSARILY WAS HE INVOLVED
IN THE TACK THAT KILLED 13
AMERICAN SERVICE MEMBERS.
>> THAT WAS MY NEXT QUESTION.
WE BELIEVE HE WAS THE LEADER OR
A LEADER OF ISIS-K?
>> MY SOURCES SAY THIS WAS AN
ISIS-K PLANNER.
THE ISIS BRANCH IN AFGHANISTAN,
A SPLINTER GROUP FROM THE ISIS
GROUP IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
HE WAS PLANNING ADDITIONAL
ATTACKS, NOT NECESSARILY THE
ATTACK OUTSIDE THE KABUL AIRPORT
THAT KILLED 13 AMERICAN SERVICE
MEMBERS.
THIS WAS A PLANNER, NOT
NECESSARILY EVEN A LEADER.
NOTICE THE STATEMENT FROM U.S.
CENTRAL COMMAND.
DOESN'T SAY THE ISIS-K LEADER.
PLANNER.
>> WORDS DO MATTER.
NONETHELESS, WE'RE MAKING THEM
PAY AS THE PRESIDENT PROMISED
YESTERDAY.
I SAW THE PHRASE VERY OVER THE
HORIZON."
DO WE KNOW WHETHER THIS STRIKE
CAME FROM THE KABUL AIRPORT,
CAME FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE?
>> THERE'S NO DRONES AT THE
KABUL AIRPORT.
THEY PLAY FROM THE MIDDLE EAST
IN THE UNITED ARAB EMIRATES.
IT'S AN EIGHT-HOUR FLIGHT AND
HAVE TO GO FROM PAKISTAN.
YOU ONLY HAVE ANT FOUR OR FIVE
HOURS FROM OVERHEAD.
THAT'S WHERE THE DRONE STRIKE
WAS LAUNCHED.
THE ONLY AIR ASSETS ARE APACHE
GUN SHIPS.
>> COULD BE THE INDICATION OF
THE OVER THE HORIZON CAPACITY
NECESSARY ONCE THE TROOPS LEAVE.
ANY NEWS AS WELL ON
INTELLIGENCE?
WHERE WE GOT IN INFORMATION
FROM?
>> IT'S NOT CLEAR RIGHT NOW.
THE U.S. MILITARY KEEPS A RANGE
OF ASSETS IN THE AIR, NOT JUST
DRONES BUT OTHER THINGS.
I'LL JUST LEAVE IT THERE.
THE U.S. MILITARY IS SCRAMBLING
ALL ASSETS TO FIND OUT WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE AND WHO MIGHT BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OTHER ATTACKS.
IN YOUR ALERT, THE STATE
DEPARTMENT PUT OUT ANOTHER
WARNING TELLING AMERICANS IF
THERE'S ANY OUTSIDE THE GATES OF
THE AIRPORT IN KABUL TO EXIT
IMMEDIATELY, LEAVE IMMEDIATELY.
IT'S CLEAR THE U.S. MILITARY AND
THE STATE DEPARTMENT DO NOT WANT
CROWDS OUTSIDE THE GATES.
THE THREAT WARNING.
GENERAL McKENZIE, THE HEAD OF
U.S. CENTRAL COMMAND WARNED THAT
FUTURE ATTACKS WERE LIKELY AND
POTENTIALLY IMMINENT.
PERHAPS THIS TOOK OUT A LEADER
PLANNING A FUTURE ATTACK IN THE
NEXT COUPLING DAYS.
WE STILL HAVE 5,000 U.S. TROOPS
ON THE RAMP AT THE KABUL
AIRPORT, PETE.
>> THESE ARE INITIAL RECORDS.
SO WE DON'T WANT TO GET TOO FAR
AHEAD OF OURSELVES AND
SPECULATE.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT WOULDN'T BE
INCONCEIVABLE THAT INTEL FROM
THIS TYPE COULD COME FROM
TALIBAN SOURCES.
DO WE KNOW HOW LINKED OR
UNLINKED THESE GROUPS ARE?
PEOPLE WERE JARRED THAT THE
TALIBAN WAS WILLING TO LET
ISIS-K FIGHTERS OUT OF JAIL.
DO WE KNOW HOW INTEL MIGHT BE
FLOWING ON THIS?
>> YOU STRUCK ON SOMETHING
IMPORTANT.
EARLIER TODAY JENNIFER GRIFFIN
ASKED JOHN KIRBY ASKED HOW MANY
ISIS FIGHTERS WERE SPRUNG FROM
PRISONS AROUND AFGHANISTAN WHEN
THE TALIBAN TOOK OVER.
JOHN KIRBY SAID THOUSANDS.
ISIS AND THE TALIBAN HAVE FOUGHT
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER.
FOR YEARS JOINT SPECIAL
OPERATIONS COMMAND WERE LAUNCHES
RAIDS IN EASTERN AFGHANISTAN IN
NANGARHAR WHERE ISIS BRANCH IN
AFGHANISTAN IS BASED.
SO IN RECENT YEARS, BECAUSE OF
THE ISIS FIGHTING THE TALIBAN,
THEY WERE ALSO A DEFACTOR
ALLIANCE.
THE U.S. WAS LAUNCHING DRONE
STRI